when we hear the word dubai most of us
picture towering skyscrapers immense
wealth police with lamborghinis seven
star hotels with the absolute cream of
society inside them also the palm
islands the world islands the burj
khalifa the burj burjal arab futuristic
symbols of incredible wealth and so in
light of all that i'm here to make the
case that dubai the emirates and the
gulf countries in general are one of the
worst places on the planet now this is a
rather bold claim i realize but it's one
that i can substantiate fully so let's
take a look at what's really behind the
glitz and glamour the true face of dubai
and the gulf countries to better
understand what's going on in a place
like dubai first let's talk about
romania
[Music]
in the decades following world war ii
bukash the capital came to face the same
problem as many eastern european
capitals did at the time as urbanization
increased and huge residential areas
were built out the need arose for new
high-capacity public transportation and
so nikola chochasku the dictator of
romania by candidate gave out the order
to construct a metro line and so the
engineers created a line proposal and
presented it to him and then ceosku was
like
no i will design the route personally
and so the former shoemaker assistant
who also called himself the genius of
the carpathians i am not making this up
sat down and redesigned the entire metro
line to have it run along the river
underneath yes along but nikola
chochesko's wife elena ciaosku a former
textile factory worker also got her fair
share of planning reportedly when the
planners presented the final version of
the metro line to the chochester couple
elena chorchesko reportedly asked why
the metro would stop inside the inner
city at piata romana inquiring what kind
of factories there are the planners told
her there aren't any factories but there
is the bukras university of economics
where there are lots of students hearing
that elena chaucesque reportedly said
students they've gotten fat they grew up
belly they should walk no station at
ravana let them walk and so since nikola
chorchesku added nothing to that and
nobody else dared to oppose his wife the
station was axed from the plans but of
course everyone outside of the dictator
power couple knew that this was [ __ ]
stupid and so the engineers having
enough foresight decided to build the
station in secret banking on the fact
that they would need to build a station
there anyway due to future public
pressure and they were correct the end
result was this ridiculous and
dangerously narrow station since the
engineers couldn't build a normal
station hall since they had to disguise
their little secret project as regular
tunnel boring and so the moral of the
story is smooth brain dictator plus
construction equals dumb [ __ ] and boy
what a perfect segue this is to the
video's actual subject dubai
[Music]
the city of dubai is a [ __ ] joke it's
a tasteless parody of everything wrong
with modern humanity and so why do i say
that let's go through it shall we
now in my video about skyscrapers i have
already talked about the butch khalifa
it's a big dumb tower of glass and steel
stuck in the middle of the desert
serving no other purpose than a
petrodollar fuel dick measuring contest
and the building even has its own poem
about itself like seriously how
pretentious can you get i am the life
force of collective aspirations and the
aesthetic union of many cultures i
seriously dream stupid emotions and what
the hell is that noise oh no it's the
poop trucks yeah did you know that the
burj khalifa isn't connected to its
sewage system so every single day a huge
line of poop trucks have to queue up
next to the building and suck out all
the poop so amar's ambition and dubai's
shining dream included the world's
tallest skyscraper but not a sewer
system and besides i've talked about
this before in the skyscrapers video
there's actually not much point to
building a skyscraper like the only
situation where it might make sense is
when you're physically out of space but
trust me dubai does not have this
problem which ties into the next
suspects
[Music]
dubai's palm islands are the og symbols
of the city the construction of the
first one the palm jumeirah started in
2001 if you can believe that and
according to google's satellite images
it's still not finished it's still
getting built out and just for good
measure let's take a look at what they
actually built here i mean these things
do look nice from space but what are
they really from up close and personal
well the stem is an eight-lane urban
freeway and the leaves are just
individual suburban streets oh and
there's also a monorail in the middle oh
and between the point and nakil mall
there are no stations so then how do
people living on the leaves get on this
thing well it's a rhetorical question of
course just like the real suburbs in
america this thing was built around cars
and the second poem the jebe alley will
be more the same and then there are the
world islands of course which are just a
complex of tiny islands for the ultra
rich and their villas and oh my god this
looks outright post-apocalyptic jesus
christ oh and there's a third bomb under
construction if the two weren't enough
oh and by the way the sand they use for
the palms is not desert sand they can't
use it because the grains are too big
instead they have to get the sand from
the sea floor and they achieved this by
sucking it up with these big tanker
ships and also annihilating acres of
marine life in a process oh and by the
way these palm islands were built on top
of natural coral reefs which they just
ended up basically burying oh and
according to nasa measurements all these
islands are sinking at a rate of five
millimeters per year and by the way have
you heard about this thing called the
rising sea levels according to the
environment agency abu dhabi under the
most severe climate change scenario
nearly all of dubai including the palm
islands would be under water alright so
let me get this straight you had all the
money and power in the world to create
anything and you have paid money to
annihilate a coral reef to build a
sinking suburb on top of it perhaps i
treated you too harshly
and here's the kicker about these
islands that's right i'm still not done
why build them on the sea to begin with
i mean you have the desert you have all
the space you will ever need so why not
just build the palms inverted into the
land you know having the actual body of
the palm not out of sand but out of
water it would look just as impressive
from space and it wouldn't even demolish
all the aquatic life hang on a second
they did do something like this already
just below the palm tree and oh no these
are american style suburbs oh man i
can't believe it they took the worst
urbanism practices from the us and they
implemented it one to one and we
actually have all the circles of
urbanism hell in here copy-paste housing
cul-de-sacs giant highways coming
through the area no public
transportation a 12 lane arterial road
jesus christ and so this will be our
segway to
dubai's urbanism in general is just
complete bonkers it's kind of its own
little bubble really a strange little
rich people's dystopia in the desert
take a look at this arrangement two
sections of skyscrapers separated by a
20-something lane freeway and behind it
a bunch of cul-de-sac suburbs and golf
courses is this strange mixture between
futurama and evil los angeles and this
just makes me feel so frustrated because
all that money and all that power they
could have done so much more and so much
better than this the way i understand it
the main motive behind building all this
flashy stuff was to try and increase
tourism to help the emirates economy
transition away from oil revenues which
is you know fair enough but then why not
build something truly unique something
that isn't just a big dumb tower of
glass and steel or a couple dozen
suburban streets on sinking sandbanks or
gigantic malls or golf courses imagine a
city with full-on historic arabic golden
eater architecture with modern elements
ok this is concept art from diablo 3 but
you get the idea i have seen skyscrapers
malls suburbs urban freeways or golf
courses before what i haven't seen is a
historical or at least historicist arab
city that would be a great way of
spending all those petrol dollars or at
least a better way i would say and that
might even attract a more quality crowd
instead of the oligarchs trust fund
babies and noverish idiots okay that's a
bit unfair but dubai right now is not
exactly a haven of intellectualism so to
speak by the way did you know that only
10 percent of the emirates population is
actually emirati the other 90 being
immigrants and expats well actually
they're all immigrants it's just that
white people came up with this word
expat so they don't have to call
themselves immigrants abroad because
that word is reserved for brown people
speaking of which
and this right here is my biggest
problem with dubai the emirates and the
gulf states in general all that luxury
wealth and opulence you see all around
you in dubai rests on a mountain of
human tragedies poor people from third
world countries such as india pakistan
and bangladesh are lured in by work
agencies promising high wages and stable
employment people take loans from
friends and family so they can cover the
cost of their travel and work visa
usually more than two thousand dollars
despite emirati law requiring the
companies to pay for those upon arrival
workers passports are often confiscated
essentially trapping them inside the
country workers are forced to work up to
12-hour shifts up to seven days a week
for 175 dollars per month on average
wager years are common many workers not
receiving money for months on end to
quote from a human rights watch report
the impact on workers whose wages are
withheld for even one month is very
serious they immediately fall into
arrears on the death day of recruiting
agencies in their home countries they
incur additional interest and they are
unable to send money home for their
families who depend on their income
earning the emirates in some cases the
known payment of wages means that
workers do not have money to buy food or
basic goods and end up borrowing money
just to survive the coveyed epidemic
only made things worse that and the oil
price crashing left many workers jobless
consequently many were abandoned by
their former employers they now spend
their days in half abandoned worker
camps on the outskirts of the city only
volunteers and their food donations
standing between them and starvation a
guardian article quotes a construction
worker called hassan he says guests on
and off visit and give something but
when nobody comes we have to starve we
have nothing all this just a few
kilometers away from the seven star
hotels the world's tallest skyscraper
the world's biggest mall and the golf
courses for rich foreigners according to
the estimates of the commonwealth human
rights initiative between 2012 and
mid-2018 more than 10 indian workers
died in gulf countries every single day
and these are just the indians in
addition to that a jezebel article goes
on to say that at least two indians
commit suicide every single week in the
emirates a number they say that is
simultaneously both shocking yet
unsurprising they show photos of the
accommodation the workers have to endure
unfit even for animals a harsh contrast
to instagram's parallel universe they
call this system modern slavery and i'm
afraid they are correct this and the
previously mentioned issues but
especially this is why i hate the
emirates and especially [ __ ] hate
dubai
the city of dubai is a [ __ ] joke one
that's unusually cruel it's a twisted
parody of everything wrong with modern
humanity i'll leave you with a poem from
berthold brecht written in 1935 titled
questions from a worker who reads
who built thieves of the seven gates in
the books you will read the names of
kings did the kings haul up the lumps of
rock and babylon many times demolished
who raised it up so many times in what
houses of gold glittering lima did its
builders live where the evening that the
great wall of china was finished did the
masons go great room is full of
triumphal arches who erected them over
whom did the caesar's triumph had
byzantium much raised in song only
palaces for its inhabitants
even in fabled atlantis the night that
the ocean engulfed it the drowning still
cried out for their slaves the young
alexander conquered india was he alone
caesar defeated the gauls did he not
even have a cook with him
philip of spain wept when his armada
went down was he the only one to weep
frederick the second won the seven years
war who else won it every page of
victory who cooked the feast for the
victors
every 10 years a great man
who paid the bill
so many reports so many questions
thank you for watching uh i'm sorry the
video took such a dark journey in the
end but as i was looking up stuff for
dubai for the video i kept encountering
more and more just alarming the [ __ ]
up information like jesus christ
anyway thank you for watching once again
and please like and subscribe if you
haven't already and do check out my
patreon tiers link in the description
and i'll see you next time